on camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview why we'll
explain why how do you feel about that
influence that you had you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm
going to do you're going to Res I'm
going I've been answering your question
you answer mine it's actually not my job
to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV well tonight on pebg on sent of the
UK's plan to send Asylum Seekers to
Rwanda is ruled unlawful by the Supreme
Court unanimously PM sunak says he still
hasn't given up is it time though to
forget this Fiasco and take the migrant
crisis seriously we debate Israeli
forces enter the biggest Hospital in
Gaza claiming it's a terrorist Command
Center Hamas called calls that a war
crime I'll talk live to Mark
reg labor faces a wave of resonations of
its leaders refusing to call for
ceasefire in Gaza as tempers flare over
anti-Semitism a pro Palestine protest
and that Jeremy Corbin interview I'm
joined with his uncensored debut by
leftwing Firebrand his words not mine
Owen
[Music]
Jones live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to Pi
Morgan on sensor the government's plan
to send Asylum Seekers to Rwanda was the
headline grabbing centerpie of its plan
to fix Britain's migrant crisis prime
minister rishy sunak has made stopping
the small boats crossing the channel one
of his five pledges to the British
people the test by which he wants to be
measured at the next election well saxel
braan even said it was her dream to see
migrants deported to Rwanda now like the
montypython parrot sketch the government
says that dream is just resting well bad
news this parrot is no more it has
ceased to be it's expired and gone to
meet its
maker this is a late
parent it's a stiff bre of life it rests
in peace couldn't it put it better
myself Cy the Rwanda plan is As Dead As
SW Bran's career as Home Secretary and
it's time for the government to move on
the bottom line with this is it was
never going to work I said that at the
time I've said it throughout and I'm
saying it again when the Supreme Court
has also basically agreed tens of
thousands of people are crossing the
channel illegally every year when they
get here they enter a broken and chaotic
system beset by chronic unforgivably
large backlogs sending a tiny handful of
of people to Rwanda at vast public
expense was never either practical or a
Humane solution now the Supreme Court
has reiterated that it's illegal genuine
assignment Seekers would face the
serious risk of ending up back in the
country they escaped from so far the
government has given 140 million pounds
of our money to Rwanda in exchange for
precisely nothing so it's all an
embarrassing Fiasco for Richi sudak his
government and the country and the only
person benefiting from all that is saki
stama his Rwanda scheme cooked up with
his national security threat Home
Secretary has blown up he was told over
and over again that this would happen
that it wouldn't work and it was just
the latest Tory gimmick gimi but he bet
everything on it and now he's totally
exposed the central pillar of his
government has crumbled beneath him does
he want well plenty of people are lining
up to argue this is something kind of a
fronted democracy newspaper columnist I
think that's what he is now Boris
Johnson called it a legal blockade on
Rwanda which is obviously absurd now
some conservatives are clamoring for the
UK to exit the European convention on
human rights or just ignore the Supreme
Court altogether yes Lee Anderson who's
at the moment the deputy chairman of the
conservative party the party of Law and
Order called on the prime minister to
brazenly break the law and put planes in
the air now
that's exactly the kind of careless
brainless and heartless thinking that
got us into this mess but you can see
more of that on GB news when Mr Anderson
has a show the UK does have a migrant
crisis the numbers speak for themselves
Rwanda though is always a distraction
not a solution now it's time for the
government to put its time and money
into finding an actual solution that
works well with me in the studi talk
TV's International editor Isabelle
oakshaw associate of the mirror Kevin
McGuire and talk TV contributor to
Esther CRA you're welcome to all of you
all right
Isabelle it's dead dead as a doornail
it's it's pushing up the daisies it's an
ex parrot this deal it is a complete ex
parrot it should never have been a
parrot in the first place I mean
gimmicks would work if it's a symbolic
thing that you can actually make happen
but it was blindingly obvious from the
start that there were never going to be
a lot of deportations to Rwanda you
didn't need to go through this agonizing
and incredibly expensive and time
wasting process to tell us that and you
know hats off to Rich un for attempting
to make it look like he had a plan you
know that he was seizing the initiative
that he was not to be deterred by this
supreme court because big Wows were
going to come up with some emergency
legislation which will then itself be
challenged again and again they haven't
got time I mean that's to his point
there's a ticking clock right he's only
got a year till he has to call an
election they're never going to get what
they need to do to even get this back on
the table in time so this is dead for
for this government anyway um what do
you make of this I mean the problem is
at the at the root of this is a real
problem well of course you know the
small boats issue is not something that
is a small problem it's something that
enrages the British public that tens of
thousands of people come in here
illegally brought here by you know
unscrupulous greedy Smugglers who don't
care if the people they bring over live
or die it's a humanitarian crisis in
that regard it's a ridiculous that our
country's border is so transparently
poorest they keep want to pour in um and
at the root of it is a system and just
doesn't work 30,000 people on the Asylum
backlog why can't we just do the basics
in it's 130,000 plus 130,000 Sor 130,000
people on the waiting this right I mean
this is a ridiculous for a country like
us well of course but the the question
is what exactly is the government
supposed to do about you can't turn them
back you know can no but this they're
not doing it that's the point and this
is this is the issue here this is an
existential crisis for the conservative
party because it goes against every
principle it goes against law and order
it goes against fairness and meritocracy
at the end of the day the amount of
money we spend on these Boat Crossings
is more than the budget for homelessness
in the UK it's you two are both
conservatives right identify as
conservatives and yet you're both
instinctively very hostile about this
which is because the answer is simple
the answer is simple turn them away
refuse refuse their assign these okay
I'm going
no but we're hostile to the situation
because at the end of the day these
people are not genuine Asylum Seekers
they're mostly able boded men economic
migrants people the people are Asylum
system should be prioritizing women and
children who are at higher risk of
sexual uh abuse and violence sex sex
sexual based violence are at the bottom
of the list because of right the number
of people the number of people crossing
in boats is 30,000 this year last year
it was 45,000 so it's coming down that's
partly because the government's spending
half a billion pounds with a French to
stop the sings but the government's own
figures the government own figures the
government's own the government's own
figures showed that Rwanda was going to
cost
£69,000 per head which is £63,000 more
than allowing people to stay here and
that's before you allow them to if you
allow them to work is's right the reason
for the falling number is mainly young
male economic migrants from Albania
we've done a deal with the Albanian
government and they're not coming but
yes but there is the answer you do the
deals with govern you stop the say now
when people do people right away if
that's if that's work so effectively my
question for Rishi sun is well go and do
more deals like that EXA and if the
French are being obstinate as they are
they they don't want this problem on
their hands right then you got to try
and do a deal that they will accept the
majority of the we've already well we've
already sent them tens of millions I
mean enormous amounts of money which
have achieved
the the majority of people who do get
here on boats are granted the right to
stay because they have a no because they
have a legal right they the government
is trying to use the channel as you
legal do you know part of these migrants
are Indian students coming from Serbia
because Serbia has a Visa free waiver
with Indians they are not genuine
as no let's contextualize since 2018 the
population ofall have crossed the
channel right it's that is that is a we
can all agree it's wrong and clearly
15,000 fewer people are coming because
of the Albanian economic migrants coming
over then that clearly is a problem as
well but there will definitely be some
legitimate as Seekers and refugees by
the way have come from countries that we
Bond right so we a moral duty to take
care of well we went there they went
there they come here it's a backhanded
compliment they want to come here start
a new life work and pay their you know
who we have a moral duty to the women
and children that they are leaving if
they're in such a desperate
situation we can all agree it's a
absolute Horror Story right I'm not
against it on principle by the way
because I think that if we were actually
able to do it it would stop the flow of
migrants I'm against it because it was
flawed from the start because we were
never going to get how we would never
get it
to I would be might happen we've had six
in six years so let's assume you're
number seven I would be working with the
ministry of defense to turn back the
boats whatever the legal niceties I
would be turning back the boats it's
been done in other countries actually
Belgium is doing it and once you start
turning them back they will stop coming
right because I remember pretty Patel
said this and then royal royal Navy was
was the royal Navy was uh deployed Royal
Navy sailors are going to try and use
their boat to push back a ding you now
they'll capsize it and people will die
austr Australians have done
this the Australians done this and we've
consulted why can't we just do it the
Australians those boats are huge boats
so make
Bo if you try to do the Australian
system here it would be ruled quite
rightly unlawful now the Rwanda deal it
was country was cruel it was unworkable
it was expensive it's AAL the Australian
thing it worked brilliantly there are no
more boats do do you know what happens
in those camps that they send them the
level the levels of suicide and ill
health well they is that is that really
is that really what
you really what you want excuse your
Humanity suicides on the people the
people heart smuggling these individuals
and taking money from them not the
government's defending their borders I'm
sorry that's what a country means a
country has borders by not having safe
and legal Roots
people you are you are a business
manager for the people's Smugglers you
are sending people people Smugglers how
by them away the majority of people once
they cross in those boats are given a
legal right to stay that doesn't mean
they should be exactly it me our system
is if you've actually looked at the
criteria by which their cases of judg
they are ludicrous I think we could do
ourselves a massive favor if we just
special show started by processing the
people faster I mean the first thing I
would do if I was James cleverly is
massively increase the number of people
processing these applications so at the
very least you get that number
right down they should be turned around
within a week exactly what's what's the
point of processing just letting more
people in they allowed the backlog to go
over 170,000 they are now putting more
resources in it's come down to 130,000
now I'm all all this money we're
spending at the moment on Rwanda 150
million put that into more processing
yeah unfortunately appears we paid
it we're going to keep we're going to
we're going to keep spending money on
this Folly right well well which is
madness but do you know the difference
between the EU acceptance rates for
Asylum Seekers and the UK 37% versus 77%
there's a reason why when in the safe
country of France they choose to risk
coming here ask isab how damaging I mean
it's been a fascinating week for Richie
sun he he has to sack his Home Secretary
which I think was the right thing to do
I think she defied his authority and you
can't have that as prime minister and
she did it brazenly uh then he woke up
this morning to quite good news right
that he'd hit one of his five pledges
inflation has hared it's come down well
still going up let's remember the cost
of things going but it's come down it's
going up everywhere but it's come down a
lot faster than was predicted that's a
tick in his pledge box and yet he
couldn't even celebrate that before this
happened so it's a it's been a turbulent
week for him I think it's catastrophic
actually I think this is absolutely as
said this is existential you know I got
the email dear Isabelle have you checked
out our promises from the chancellor
saying you know great news inflation is
half yeah I've checked out your promises
one of the main ones was that you were
were going to stop the boats and you
have abjectly failed to do that got I
interview she said he didn't say
completely stop he said he would stop
this yeah she had stopped the boats on
pod that was the slogan but they have
stopped a lot of the boats I mean that's
if if you looked at the tnc's it was he
was going to pass legislation to stop he
he gave the impression he was going to
stop the boat there's no government if
labor labor come in they will not
completely stop the boats because even
if you allow the people who are entitled
to seek asylum in the UK to come through
safe and legal Roots those who aren't
fin does RI moving more to the center
right and abandoning people like swell
bravman on the more extremity of the
right is that going to be better for him
at the at the election no because what
matters is him actually acting instead
of you know moving whichever way he
wants at the end of the day he has acted
in his much not not really though
because he hasn't stopped the in as much
as I agree with a lot of suel bravman
what she said I think she's a very
unskilled untalented politician I think
she's very callous every time she opened
hery God exactly she said something that
made my skin C but the thing is she's an
AM she's an amateur the thing is they
brought it on themselves these people
it's a lifestyle Choice she was way out
of her depth and the government is
better without her you why no sympathy
because she may be jobless but that's a
lifestyle Choice um let's get her a tent
exactly chip in wouldn't that be ironic
uh thank you to my back uh good to see
you all and S the next is hisra defense
for continue their raid at the alshifa
hospital in Gaza I'll be joined by
senior advisor to prime minister
Netanyahu Mark
[Music]
Reg
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to PB sens interview with
Jeremy coring which I repeatedly asked
him 15 times or more actually if he
believed Hamas as a terror group made it
to prime minister's questions today
prime minister Richi sunak even said
this while criticizing SEC dama but he
talks about apologizing he talks about
the former member not being a labor MP
now yes he wasn't a labor MP when he
declined 15 different times to say that
herass was a terrorist organization this
week which is shameful but he was a
labor MP indeed The Honorable gentleman
served with him he told the country he
would make a great prime minister at
that point he described her mass of
friends does he want to apologize for
that now not a not a bad question uh
well let's just have a little replay of
Jeremy Corbin's inability to answer two
simple
questions are they a terror group look
PE can say it peers can we have a
discuss say can we have a discussion can
you call them a terror group can we have
a disc you call them a terror group is
it possible to have a r
are you prepared to call teror is it
possible to have a rational with you is
it possible come on answer that question
you answer it no it's my show you answer
my
question well I'm going to be joined in
a moment by the Socialist commentator
Owen Jones making his eagerly awaited
debut on peers Morgan uncensored but
first we're going to go to Mark regive
who's the senior advisor to Israel's
prime minister Benjamin Neto and a
former ambassador to the United Kingdom
Mr Reger thank you very much indeed for
joining me um I want to ask ask you
specifically about the alifa hospital
and what is actually happening there
because the IDF have said they've gone
in and they have proven that this was
being used as a command center by Hamas
Hamas say no they haven't that's is
actually what's been going on there is a
war crime a deliberate attack on a
hospital I've got to say that the so far
the evidence that the IDF has published
in terms of videos and pictures and so
on I don't think it's overly compelling
it doesn't look like to me like a
command Senter it looks to me like a
hospital which has got uniforms and some
military hardware and some firearms and
so on but it doesn't look to me like the
central hub for Hamas in
Gaza so patients will we'll be providing
more information as we becomes available
not all the information we have at the
moment we can make public and I can
understand why you'd want to see it but
let's be clear it's not just the
government of Israel that says Hamas has
a command and control and its military
Network underneath the hospital the US
government said it two days ago the
Pentagon and the White House and the
truth is uh that the O people who live
there in the region in the city of Gaza
the Palestinians themselves there it's
the worst kept secret that Hamas has
everybody knows that Hamas has a
military structure under the hospital I
mean the reason it's so important is as
you know uh Article 19 of the Geneva
convention which is what governs the way
Warfare is conducted says the protection
to which civilian hospitals are entitled
shall not cease unless they're used to
commit outside the humanitarian duties
acts harmful to the enemy protection May
however cease only after due warnings
been given naming in all appropriate
cases a reasonable time limit and after
such warning has remained unheeded so is
your position uh that Israel has
meticulously stuck by the letter of that
article of the Geneva Convention in
relation to the alifa hospital 100% 100%
we've given an adequate warning we've
urged civilians to leave the area uh
we've done so I think three and a half
weeks ago we started asking civilians to
leave and the truth is Bears the
overwhelming majority of of civilians
have left some one million people have
left that area of Northern Gaza have
heeded Our advice moved South out of
Harm's Way because we didn't want to see
them caught up in the crossfire between
the Israeli Defense Forces and the the
terrorists of Kamas what do you say to
somebody like me who has spent six weeks
now debating this who believes October
the 7th was one of the worst Terror
attacks of modern times that Israel
absolutely has not only a right to
defend itself but a fundamental duty to
its people to protect them particularly
given the Hamas spokesman last week said
we're going to try and do this again and
again and again that is next essential
threat to Israel I get that I believe
Hamas has to be removed it cannot be
removed peacefully it has to be removed
uh militarily in my estimation but the
question then
becomes how much of the civilian
casualties that we're seeing becomes too
much not just for Israel and any moral
align that you may have here but for the
wider International Community which is
already as we're seeing in England today
there's been a big uh a big vote in
Parliament many people resigning from
the labor Shadow bench because of what's
going on and wanting a ceasefire what do
you say to people like me that believe
that you are right in principle but that
the execution of what is happening in
Gaza is getting so bad that it borders
on
unjustified so the first thing I would
argue is it's crucial that we get rid of
Kamas we saw the sort of violence Hamas
is capable of inflicting upon innocent
civilians you yourself just said October
7th was horrific and brutal and it's
clear that we cannot tolerate the
continued existence of this Terror
Enclave on our Southern frontier Israeli
parents should not have to live in fear
of terrorists crossing the border in the
middle of the night and and and
murdering their children so getting rid
of Kamas is the AIM now if it was
possible to send a letter to the
Secretary General of the United Nations
and say please demilitarize Gaza and get
rid of Kamas I'd like to do it that way
it' be easier for everyone but that's
just not a realistic option we have to
send our troops in and we have to
dismantle through a military conflict
the hamas's military machine there's no
alternative if you have another
alternative I'm happy to hear it now
we've made maximum efforts to reduce the
numbers of Civilian uh casualties uh we
really have tried it's very difficult
because Kamas has embedded itself as we
see with the hospital inside civilian
structures it uses gaza's civilians as a
human shield nonetheless we've because
of our warnings some 1 million Northern
garans have fled the nor G strip move to
the South which is safer than the North
and we are still making a maximum effort
today to distinguish between those
civilians who've remained who are not
our Target and the Kamas terrorists but
peers you you've been around you know
that there hasn't been a war in modern
history where civilians haven't been
caught up in crossfire no that is true
here's what I would say to that here's
what I would say I heard Jeremy Bowen
the BBC's Middle East editor today
saying he hasn't seen Devastation of the
kind uh that's happened in Gaza which
he's now witnessed
uh since uh Aleppo after the Russians
had been in and that was apocalyptic and
I guess my question of you is yeah you
you've persuaded a million gazans to
head south what are they coming back to
everything that they had is being
disintegrated it's just being vaporized
there's nothing left for these people to
come back to is there I I agree and it's
clear that when this is over Gaza will
have to become demilitarized
deradicalized and rebuilt
and ultimately though I know it's very
difficult for the civilian population of
Gaza who are going through what is a
traumatic experience they're going
through a war it's not easy understand
that but ultimately when this is over it
will be better for them too what has 16
years of Kamas rule bought the people of
Gaza
Bloodshed suffering impoverishment Hamas
has nothing to show for its time in
government except for those bad things
the people of Gaza also deserve better
than the current dict torial terrorist
regime that has ruled them I mean a
final question I would have for you is
simply this is that Gaza has an
extremely high percentage of population
are children these scenes of thousands
of kids and babies being killed on a
hourly basis are obviously horrific how
do you know that what you're doing with
this uh war is not just instinctively to
me creating as many people fear Elon
must touched on this and others uh just
radicalizing a whole new generation of
people who've seen their young brothers
sisters and so on uh killed in this
offensive do you not worry that you're
just creating a whole new problem down
the line of a newly radicalized
Gaza can I offer with your permission a
a counterargument and that is exactly
the opposite will happen that the people
of Gaza will see that the path of
violence and terrorism and brutality
that is Hamas
will be totally discredited it'll be
discredited they'll understand that the
path of extremism hurts them more than
it hurts us that it's a dead end and
that that will create space once we've
defeated Hamas and its whole ideology
has been discredited that'll create
space for more moderate and pragmatic
voices to fill the void and that's good
for the future Mark regiv I hope you're
right thank you for joining me I
appreciate it thanks for having me on
say next tonight socialist commentator
not spoken man of the left Owen Jones
joins me live in the studio for his
uncensored debut he's been listening
intently to that last interview I'm sure
they have some strong views we'll find
out after the
[Music]
break we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent Republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
scon
are you actually speech rating for the
I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to take
the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose L
not stop pying to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X formly known as
Twitter where is our where is our unbias
news going to come from Welcome to the
talk it's really great to be back my
Little Darlings kids think all they have
to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then yeah problem problem solved
there you go who's fit as a buch your do
him all right but but he's now middle
class three us here t i nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
know you're probably going to me
up this is talk
[Music]
TV
well join me now as the Socialist
commentator Owen JS Owen youve been
sitting there patiently your response to
Mark regiv there a grotesque inversion
of reality I mean the thing about
Israeli spokesperson like that is if I
was told the sky was blue I'd go out the
window and Jack just to be sure what did
he say that's wrong um for one thing
talking about um the hospital being used
as a terror base now let's just bear in
mind that Israel's spokespeople have a
long track record of lying through that
back teeth when shot in the head for
example Shireen Abu akley they said for
months and months and months it was
Palestinian goodmen it wasn't they shot
her in the head James Miller a brilliant
British documentary work uh filmmaker
shot dead 2002 by the Israelis years
later of course you wouldn't believe
Hamas in their version of events either
would you well I that's why I depend on
what Aid agencies are the United Nations
are saying on the ground which is that
Collective punishment is being Unleashed
against the Palestinian people I mean
look we can see already the evidence
they've been um unveiling for what they
said was a a terror Hub including
showing CDs and a computer what they've
done to that hospital is firstly because
they cut off energy in a total Siege
which they justified by saying they were
fighting Human animals which should be
considered genocidal rhetoric has been
condemned as such well it should
certainly be condemned and they should
not have the ability uh Israel to cut
off water thank you
power that is collective punishment
juste
under article 33 that's against the law
it's a war crime can we AG I think we
should have some consensus I would I
would argue you're heading towards
Collective punishment when you do that
you're not heading towards Collective
punishment when you cut off energy and
water to the of any population ex to
play Devil's Advocate and to give their
side of it which I've heard repeatedly
take the issue of fuel they want to try
and get fuel in the Israelis as they've
said to the hospitals to the
humanitarian side of this but they know
that Hamas are taking that fuel and
using it for their military the hospital
authorities who we should listen to have
rebutted those accusations look what we
what's happened here is babies right now
are gasping for breath yes and
suffocating we've had several nurses and
patients shot dead in fact this whole
hospital has been described by medical
staff as a Mory you don't know just
quickly when a hospital just quickly
when a hospital becomes a mass grave
when dozens of decomposing bodies have
to be buried in a mass grave in a
hospital we're talking what you said can
I just quote something you said about
about ptin and and I think this was very
wise you said in March 2022 I'm seeing a
genocide want to killing women and
babies in maternity hospitals as we sit
back and let them do it why was it so
disgraceful but you were right you were
right to be here's the difference why
why why when you see this hospital is
they not the same Theory let me explain
uh because the two are in my opinion
morally very different in one case
Vladimir Putin's illegal invasion of
Ukraine he was committing war crimes
having illegally invaded a wait a second
let me finish having invaded a sovereign
Democratic country here it was Israel
that was invaded by a vast number of
terrorists who uh murdered over 1500
innocent men women children they
kidnapped 240 people including babies
children Holocaust of those so my point
is morally there is a massive difference
morally it's a massive difference now
the question of the hospital wait a sec
the question of the hospitals is this to
me they have so far produced some
evidence of Hamas operating inside the
hospital for me so far as a journalist
trying to be fair and impartial I don't
think as you've heard me say to Mart
Regan corre I don't think I've seen
enough evidence here which says to me
this was a sprawling command sensor but
there is a moral difference between what
Putin's doing in Ukraine and what
Israel's doing to defend itself against
toas isn't there hold on is no no ABS no
sorry this is the okay if if you want to
talk about that or trying to separate
them for a Ukrainian ordinary civilian
being killed or for an ordinary
Palestinian child being killed none of
them none of them did anything wrong we
agree on that don't we absolutely agree
on that now when we're talk when you
repeatedly denounced Putin for his
genocidal behavior in Ukraine do you
stand by that do you think that's a
genocide well it doesn't matter what the
what the basis for what the of course it
does no no no no no no in it no no no
Pierce in terms of what actually is
happening we can talk what about the
massacre the obscene Massacre of a
thousand Isel doing
Geno let's talk about genocide let's
talk about genocide why is it let me
tell you the difference between let me
let me put something to you and you come
back at me and tell me if I'm wrong
Hamas from its Charter onwards and from
the spokesman said last week is
dedicated to the eradication of Israel
and killing as many Jews as it can
possibly kill that is the purest
definition of genocide intent that you
will ever see and they executed it on
October the 7th as best they could now
what Israel is doing in response and
they've been very firm about this and
the international courts will rule as
they are these are very long questions
they're not I'm making I'm answering a
point and I'm putting one to you right
in my estimation they are qualitatively
different what Hamas is is publicly what
are doing is genocide what Israel is
doing is not genocide there a difference
between well Israel you could say both
Israel and Hamas have engaged in
genocidal and murderous arest I'll give
you an example yes
they is It Uncensored or not let me let
me quote let me quote what the the
Israeli authorities have said Benjamin
Netanyahu when he quoted amalec the
scriptures what does amalec say it he he
quotes amalec when they attacked the
Israelites and what God told the
Israelites to do was to destroy every
kill every man woman child and livestock
if I would put it to you an islamist
leader was quoting a similarly genocidal
passage from from the Quran you would
not I would say hesitate no no we
haven't just no you had a lot I'm going
to respond just quickly Israeli
officials said that Gaza will end up
being a city of tents with no building
standing that they are that they are
attacking for damage not for accuracy
the agricultural Minister Aid dict he
said we are rolling out a new NACA a
NACA is the mass expulsion 700,000
Palestinians in 1948 this is why
hundreds of genocide Scholars people who
are actually like you and I experts in
the field of genocide studies fear that
a genocide is taking place the
difference between Israel is Hamas does
not have the capacity to wipe at Israel
Israel is wiping Gaza off the map that's
the point that not you've actually
exposed the weakness in your argument
Israel does have the ability to kill
everyone in Gaza tomorrow and they're
not doing it in fact well hang on what
they're doing and it's indisputable they
are issuing a number of warnings
repeatedly to people to go south wait
and stay out of Northern Gaza right and
then they're pulverizing it with air
strikes and now they've gone in on the
ground and they're waging battle with
Hamas Fighters terrorists right no hang
on hang on so my point is this Israel
could if they wanted to kill everyone in
Gaza they decided not to do that is your
definition to genocide is where you want
to kill everyone sorry sorry your
definition of genocide because in
Ukraine Vladimir Putin hasn't killed
every last Ukrainian that simply not
happened no no no no he hasn't and and
nor has he stated his intention to do so
and nor as brutal and barar actually
sorry Vladimir Putin absolutely by
illegally invading a sovereign country
and indiscriminately bombing anything in
front of him indiscriminately bombing is
waging a former genocide wow
indiscriminate bombing Gaza more than
two Hiroshima bombs worth have been
dropped on East London in the space of
five weeks let me ask you two no no no
no no you said Ukraine no I'm going to
have to put this to you okay 15,000
people have now been killed now by the
Israelis estimate in Gaza one in every
200 people in Gaza have now been killed
if you were to adjust for population in
Ukraine that would be 300,000 Ukrainian
civilians 300,000 there's been a
terrible death to it's estimated by the
UN 10,000 civilians have been killed
since February last year in the space of
five weeks a country with a much much
smaller population has had a much higher
de has had a death toll higher efficy
than that that how can how can it be how
can it be that you call that genocide
but when you have nearly half the entire
civilian death toll of the Bosnian war
in a country which is twice the size in
terms of population why isn't that
genocide P well I've just answered your
question by saying if Israel wanted to
commit genocide they would simply VAP so
Russia they would VAP Russia they would
nuke they would nuke Ukraine Russia
wants to take over Ukraine yes and they
want to take over Gaza kill and it will
kill any number of ukrainians men women
and children in that process disabl the
only the death rate in is much higher
only reason it hasn't is that actually
Ukraine has a large military supported
by countries like the United States and
he's putting up one fight Ria has
nuclear weapons Russia by the way
Ukraine gave their Russia has an armed
for let me ask you what no no you've got
to accept this hang on Far a far lower
death rate in
Ukraine as expained why you haven't
explained why yes I have let me explain
Israel have made it clear hear me Israel
have made it clear that they intend to
occupy G permanently yeah and should not
be allowed to do what did what did the
Israeli Ministry leaked intelligent what
what did the intelligence Min my
interview of you I know but not your
interview of me well I think let me
answer you let me answer you well let me
ask you two questions which I asked
Jeremy cor let get these off the table
do you believe Hamas is a terror group
yes if you engage in violence against
civilian population that's terrorism I
wait don't don't do supplementaries let
me just ask you this second question
which I asked him and she couldn't
answer should herass remain in power if
I could W your magic wand then no
obviously there' been independent no let
me finish there' been independent
Palestine free of Israeli rule with a
secular Democratic movement in power the
difference I agree with when you
courageously stood against the Iraq War
yeah and you you were courageous for
doing so so what was the argument put
against you that you wanted to keep
Saddam Hussein in power even though he
gassed his own people the Kurds and
genocide many would argue that he had
invaded his neighbor and that he had uh
massacred the Shia when they rose up in
1991 now your argument against that was
that what could happen next would be far
far worse and you were right that wasn't
my argument well that is but that is did
you want to keep Sadam H in power don't
tell me what my argue was I know what it
was I was edit to the paper that waged
the campaign did AR I did not believe
that they had produced any evidence that
Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction I thought he had nothing to
do with 911 therefore we were waging a
completely irrelevant War which I
thought would stir up absolute hell in
the Middle East and you know what I was
right and actually most of the
architects of that war now ConEd they
were wrong it was a horror story from
start to finish but what it did do is sp
the rise of Isis and what the world did
with Isis was say this crosses a moral
line we have to get rid of them and we
went after Isis in places like Iraq and
Syria and other countries and in bombing
the hell out of Isis a lot of civilians
got kill you just skipped a lot of very
important history wait wait a minute no
no that's not what happened well that is
what happened no that's not what
happened one of the consequences of Thea
war was that Isis became
a very powerful for a short period of
time Global Terror Force committing
atrocity just correct your but in wiping
out Isis pretty effectively we also
killed a lot of civilians no what
actually happened what's the moral
difference between that and what
Israel's doing because you just you just
revised history what we were told that
Al-Qaeda was perhaps in League with
Sadam he's saying that was one of the
justifications of invading what actually
happened after the invasion was that it
became a playground for Al-Qaeda who
you've missed out have
noticed and what talking about we know
alaa I'm what happened for example is
fuia the city of fuia in Iraq these the
Americans went in and they massed people
protest against their Rule and many of
those Sunny populations ended up in
driven into the arms of al-Qaeda a
brutal counterinsurgency program then
resulted in resulting in Mass Slaughter
of innocent Sunny civilians and from
that Fury and anger something even worse
than Al-Qaeda emerged just as Isis yeah
and that was no I'm saying that's
exactly what we're I didn't give every
detail of the journey I said out of the
you misunderstood you've misunderstood
they engaged in a brutal
counterinsurgency I know the story
offensive against Al-Qaeda and that
caused something worse to emerge just as
in Afghanistan to just in as Afghanistan
we had two decades of occupation let me
listen we're running two decades of
occupation and the Taliban emerged
stronger than ever the same applies to
both what happened in Iraq and
Afghanistan because if you brutalize a
population will turn them into
terrorists stop talking or extremists D
them to their arms you make a lot of
good points I agree with a lot of things
you say right always have done actually
I find the way you say them as you do
with me quite annoying but that's fine
you're allowed to and we're un Sensi
come back I want to end if I can with
some kind of look we've agreed Hamas is
a terror group we've agreed they have to
go how do we actually get peace here
well firstly we have to deal with the
underlying causes of what's Driven the
Palestinian people in the case of Gaza
in G into the hands of Hamas which is
starting in 1948 the ethnic cleansing of
the Palestinian population in the naare
with 700,000 driven from their homes
murderously I might add then and
hundreds of thousands of Jews were
driven from their homes before in
Palestine well they were driven away
from Arab count hold on this they were
driven away from Arab countries yeah
from Palestine Jonathan freed wrote a
very good piece about this you know what
if you go to the history there's just
calls on both pales the Palestinians
were driven from the home 700,000 of
them and then we had the legal
settlements of colonization including in
the West Bank were completely un
remarked
alreadying legal settlements and as well
as as Amnesty International as Human
Rights Watch and betm describe it the
Israeli human rights organization a
system of a party but if you keep
brutalizing the Palestinian people
ridding them of their freedom and you
end up now in Gaza with with parents
picking up the the burned dismembered
remants of their children they will
never be Pi I agree what I would say of
that is that the on the Arab side they
have had multiple opportunities to do a
peace deal not least in 2000 with Arafat
and he walked away no what happened
there go what what was what were the
concessions because no the truth is Bill
Clinton who helped for wait a minute who
helped Forge peace in norn Ireland
brilliantly with Tony Blair and with the
others involved there that actually
Arafat they had peace in their grasp and
as Bill Clinton said to him I'm going to
end up being a failure because of you
yeah well and that revision of History
again not just from you on this program
but by Bill Clinton because they
demanded for example night land swaps
for a ratio n is come back again I love
no seriously this this conflict is not
going away it's going to continue raging
the War I think you're an important
voice in this we should keep talking
about it okay well out good to see you
see you and say the next tonight
conservative activist Charlie Kirk joins
me live for his take on what we've just
been discussing and on the state of
universities how do they got so nuts but
last Charlie after the
[Music]
break
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now tomorrow
another remarkable debate between two
influential characters with vehemently
opposing viewpoints Rabbi smoi and
Muhammad hijab well here's a preview
discussing a two-state solution if if if
two-state solution is aamas State
wanting to eviscerate Israel he doesn't
believe it but he doesn't believe in a
two solution he believes in a Final
Solution that's really scares me you
don't believe in a two solution you
believe in a final solution the way you
speak about
Jews I think it's fair to say is
probably the most ferocious debate we've
ever had on Piers Morgan uncensered and
that will be the show tomorrow night for
the hour it's the kind of debate we need
to be having but we have to see how
close we get to any kind of peace or
agreement Well for now conservative
commentator Charlie Kirk says
universities have become islands of
totalitarianism in his new book it's
called the college scam how America's
universities are bankrupting and
brainwashing away the future of
America's Youth and Charlie Kurt joins
me Charlie good to see you um this
Israel Palestine uh War and the debate
that's raging around it such passionate
views on both sides have we lost the
ability to have civilized
debate probably I mean on these campuses
it doesn't give you a lot of Hope I'll
tell you I was just at UCLA last week
and you know many of the Palestinian
forces are they have signs that say from
The River To The Sea Palestine will be
free which is basically coded language
for the abolition of the the state of
Israel but look part of what I why I
wrote the book The College scam is that
we are seeing the erosion of Western
values of free speech and dialogue and
hearing the other side you know I have
visited over 150 campuses in The Last 5
Years I'm not afraid of different ideas
and to invite that kind of dialogue and
discourse I think this Israel Palestine
issue is just the latest example in in a
variety of different ideas and topics
where we see the most radical and Fringe
ideologies come out of these University
campuses I me at Harvard University
which is considered to be the best
school in America 31 student
organizations right after the terrible
Massacre against the Jewish people on
yam kapor came out in favor of the Hamas
activity in fact some professors even
said it was justified and another ivy
league professor said that it was a
wonderful day and celebrated it so some
of the most vile and disgusting ideas
that we've seen come to the surface in
the last month uh have a point of
origination on college campuses which is
why I wrote the book The College scam
and and what's so extraordinary about
that is the very same people who've been
behaving in this way uh effectively
supporting a terror group uh have gone
out of their way to deplatform and shame
and cancel anyone who on mainly on the
right has to be on the conservative side
who've deviated from their world view so
free speech to them seems a very complex
issue no that's right and look I mean
you we have to be disciplined in how we
advocate for D you know dialogue and
free speech and when I go to these
college campuses it's come very clear
and you see this now manifesting in some
of the larger censorship regime that is
taking over the West that if a young
student finds disagree
with a conservative or somebody on the
right they don't just find the ideas
objectionable some in fact a majority by
a recent PE poll want to use Force to
try to silence and stifle and even
censor those different ideas yeah which
is the complete antithesis of what going
to University should be about I mean
Harvard that you referenced earlier just
came bottom on a uh a study of free
speech at American University bottom
almost registered zero I think or below
zero uh in other words it's the complete
opposite of A Home of free speech and
yet you would hope and expect that some
like Harvard would be a place for all
opinions uh to be discussed and debated
and challenged but it appears to be the
complete opposite unless you're out
there supporting
Hamas yes that's right well it's been
kind of ironic Pierce which for the last
decade I've been arguing for free speech
arguing that conservatives should have a
voice on campus and it's met with at
best groans or opposition and now
students for justice of Palestine and
the pro Hamas group group are the ones
saying that we want to have full free
speech we want to have rights to speak
publicly we want to have our guests on
campus which again I'm a free speech
guys so have at it but the
Administration has been very quick to
Pander to every possible demand of the
most radical groups possible on campus
when we conservatives have been asking
for kind of equal and fair treatment
over the last 10 years and it's worse
than even the Free Speech debate Pierce
it's that these these Jew hatred ideas
find a philosophical and intellectual
Foundation at so many of these
institutions I also think if you look at
things like Tik Tok for example which
obviously originates from China which
may have all sorts of vested interests
um and kids I think under 21 that it's
their main news source and if you ask uh
young people of their view of the of the
this war for example they skew massively
Pro Palestinian because they've been
bombarded all day long with very short
often woefully ill-informed takes on the
war on Tik Tok and that's their only
reference
point no that that's exactly right and I
would say that your dialogue recently
with Douglas Murray was one of the most
powerful that I've heard recently and if
every young person could hear you know
the conversation you had with Douglas
Murray I think they would have a
different opinion but they look at
almost everything through oppressor
oppressed Dynamics and that is the kind
of framing that is unfortunately pushed
forward at many of these universities
you know in a way what we've tried to do
on this show since the war started is
give a platform to to both sides if that
all sides there are people with other
views too not just Douglas but also
people on the pro Palestinian side stuff
and it's important to have that but i'
I've got an interview tomorrow night was
a debate really between two people Rabbi
schmoly and Muhammad hijab and it just
descended into one of the most
ridiculous kind of punch-ups I've ever
been involved with and that's the
sadness of this because you don't get
anywhere really when you're just trying
to kill each other metaphorically or
verbally
I don't you could hear me there Charlie
but all right don't worry we' run out of
time voes in my ear but we run out of
time and the good news is you and I have
just had a very civilized conversation
and I hope we can have it again Charlie
Kurt thank you very much indeed for
joining me I appreciate it that's it for
us tonight whatever you're up to keep it
unsensed good
[Music]
night
[Applause]
[Music]